showdown between silicon valley and the
white house appears to be diffused
but it's left some unanswered questions
about free speech and privacy
on friday twitter dropped a lawsuit
against the homeland security department
the suit was filed after dhs officials
issued a summons
demanding twitter reveal who was behind
an anti-trump account
the account called alt immigration
criticizes the department of u.s
citizenship
and immigration services it's one of
many accounts that mimic
and mock government agencies cbs news
justice reporter paula reed has been
following the developments closely
she's in our washington bureau paula
good morning good morning
first off why did the government
withdraw its demand to find out who's
behind these tweets
well i've read the request that they
sent to twitter and it's not
clear why they were looking at this
account in the first place although it
does suggest that they believe that it
is legitimate
and tweeting out legitimate information
you don't issue a summons
for a random twitter account or random
twitter troll
so it does appear that they believe this
is a legitimate account but when twitter
sued it was clear they weren't going to
win in court and they withdrew their
request
so paula do you think the goal here when
the government issued that summons was
to have a deterrent effect on
accounts like this i do i really do
think that that
was the goal of this to put them on
notice that the government is trying to
get information about who's behind this
account
but it had the complete opposite effect
this account now has
tens of thousands of new followers so
while they were trying to get
information about this account all they
really succeeded in doing
is bringing this account to the
attention of hundreds of thousands if
not millions of people
there are a lot of these so-called alt
accounts paula how far
does the first amendment extend to
protect
anonymous speech like this anonymous
speech
political speech there are broad
protections under the constitution
they want you to be able to speak out
against the government and do it
anonymously
if you fear retaliation and if some of
these accounts
are actually staffed by people who are
in the government they certainly
have reason to fear retaliation so they
will have broad protection so long as
they are not
inciting or calling for any kind of
violence paul this is not the first time
washington is faced off with silicon
valley most recently in the wake of the
san bernardino shooting the fbi
and apple faced over faced off over
access to data on the
terrace phone why is it so difficult for
washington to take on
silicon valley silicon valley is a
formidable opponent
for the federal government they have a
lot of money they have
fantastic lawyers many of whom are
previous high-level
federal attorneys and most importantly
they have the support of their customer
base
when they go to protect privacy and alex
what's so interesting about this
specific case is here
they weren't arguing over information on
the phone of a terror suspect
they appeared to be targeting the
federal government appeared to be
targeting
political dissent and if that is how the
whole
tech v federal government fight is going
to play out over the next few years
the government is going to have a really
tough time because the tech sector is
going to have the support of their
customers
their competition and a lot of the
american public the aclu
apollo said this was a victory for free
speech but i mean
is it possible we could see more cases
like this you think well
i think you will see more fights between
the tech sector and the federal
government specifically over encryption
we've had people say yes they're going
to continue
their lawsuits over encryption perhaps
targeting whatsapp or some of these
other apps but this is a little
unexpected targeting these twitter
accounts
we also can't forget twitter is one of
the president's favorite methods of
communication
so it's an interesting path for the
so-called resistance
to try to really troll him which is what
they're doing on twitter that's a very
good point paula reed thank you very
much